und heute wurde er also im Bundestag
beschlossen der ersehnte ampelhaushalt
2024 Kinder schwere Geburt der neue
schuldenbremsenkonforme Haushalt
errechnet und streng bewacht von
Finanzminister golum Lindner ja ja sieht
wahrscheinlich jeder anders auf mich
wirkt das eher mutlos das Zahlenwerk ne
ja kleinere Finanzierungslücken werden
notdürftig gestopft aber schon nächstes
Jahr könnten 20 Milliarden fehlen vor
allem aber was ist die Idee was ist der
Plan für Hälfte zwei der Ampel also
auuserhaltsregierung nicht
auseinanderbrechen aber komm jetzt muss
diese Koalition endlich als Team
geschlossen zusammenstehen hier Wolfgang
kubiki macht's vor und vergleicht die
Ampel im Karneval mit einem Schiff und
sie achten bitte am Ende mal auf das
Gesicht von Christian Lindner so und
wenn sie jetzt kreuzfahrtkapitänen weren
wohin würden sie das Schiff
steuern in einen sicheren
Hafen und mit einer anderen
[Applaus]
Mannschaft ich bring ihn ins Heim diesm
bring ich ihn ins Heim ja man kann
richtig sehen wie er es denkt ja jetzt
müssen wir fairerweise sagen fakt ist
jede Regierung hätte es im Moment unter
diesen umständ schwer aber diese
Regierung macht es sich schwer selber ja
das ist ja so kann der trotzdem noch
gelingen auch für Olaf Scholz der jetzt
erstmals in einer Umfrage zur
kanzlerpräferenz hinter Friedrich
märzfeld das muss erstmal
schaffen ist die Marke Scholz wie man in
der Werbung gerne sagt eventuell schon
verbrannt so genau dazu haben sie im
Willi Brandhaus neulich eine große
Marktforschung gestartet und die
Ergebnisse waren niederschmettern sobald
spdplakate hauptsächlich den Scholz
zeigen geht die Stimmung der Testperson
schlagartig in den Keller schlagartig ja
selbst wenn man das Motiv ändert und was
total positiv besetztes in den
Vordergrund
stellt warte mal ist das etwa der Scholz
da hinter der Zimmerpflanze da finde ich
do die Katze Scheiße es ist
wahrscheinlich
hoffnungslos wahrscheinlich ist es
hoffnungslos oder schreiben wir den
Kanzler gerade zu früh ab haben sie das
gesehen wie der Scholz und der Merz sich
vorgestern behagt haben im Bundestag WoW
oder ganz anders gefragt ist es
eventuell möglich dass Außerirdische
Olaf Scholz unbemerkt gegen einen
wütenden Klon ausgetauscht haben aber
wenn sie dann mal kritisiert werden dann
sind sie eine Mimose ich finde wer ein
wer Box der soll kein glaskin haben ich
rel bis heute warum sie davon gelaufen
sind so viel feigeit vor der eigenen
Courage habe ich noch nie
gesehen Alter
der war doch getobt
oder ja danach hat er auf dem Rednerpult
noch eine Gitarre zertrümmert ne so
Frage wie könnte diese Regierung
vielleicht doch noch überraschend die
Kurve kriegen indem man Schuldenbremse
hin oder her Geld in die Hand nimmt und
reale Sorgen der Bürger adressiert
Beispiel wohnen experten schätzen dass
die ohnehin schon horrenden mieten in
Ballungsräumen in diesem Jahr noch mal
um bis zu 20% steigen können das ist
Wahnsinn meine Damen und Herren das ist
schlicht Wahnsinn von der ja von der von
der zweiten Miete Nebenkosten mal ganz
zu schweigen ja komm ja noch dazu
400.000 Wohnung pro Jahr wollte die
Ampel bauen ne im letzten Jahr waren es
gerade mal 270 000 Tendenz fallend und
jetzt haben sie zu viel versprochen ist
das Vorhaben gescheitert das Ziel
400.000 Wohnungen das ist ja keine
ausgedachte Zahl sondern das ist die
berechnete bedarfszahl und demzufolge
halte ich auch an diesem Ziel
fest
ja wie schön klar ich meine Ziele haben
es immer toll aber wie erreichen wir die
in einer Welt in der selbst gutwillige
Bauunternehmen wegen der Kosten gar
nicht mehr sozial bauen können es geht
ja nicht
mehr vor allem weil obenrein jedes Jahr
mehr Wohnungen aus der Sozialbindung
rausfallen und zwar fallen mehr raus als
neu gebaut werden
das Thema wirgt unfassbaren sozialen
Sprengstoff in einer ohnehin
aufgeheizten Stimmung denn man darf ja
nicht vergessen für viele Menschen ist
ihre Wohnung auch ihr zu Hause
eben
ja viele wohnen immer noch bei sich zu
Hause das ist so so Bund und Länder
bezahlen jedes Jahr 20 Milliarden
Zuschüsse fürs Wohnen also für Menschen
die ihre Miete nicht mehr alleine zahlen
können 20 Milliarden investieren
gleichzeitig aber nur 4 Milliarden für
sozialen Wohnungsbau wie bescheuert ist
das denn bitte zumal man in Städten wie
München oder Hamburg wegen der
Quadratmeterpreise so auch noch
Vermieter subventioniert natürlich muss
der Staat noch viel mehr selber bauen
eine bezahlbare Wohnung ist heute ja
fast wie ein wie ein Lottogewinn was
raten sie Verbrauchern denn da im
Moment also eh ehrlich gesagt wenn man
eine Wohnung hat dann sollte man die
eher nicht
verlassen ja er hat doch recht
eigentlich darf man nicht mal mehr zum
Bäcker gehen meine Damen und Herren wenn
man zurückkommt wohnt da wer anders so
und in dieser Lage blockiert FDP
Justizminister Buschmann auch noch die
Verlängerung der
mietpreisbremse und im großen Stil
selber bauen kann die Ampel eh nicht
wegen richtig hier schließt sich der
Kreis Schuldenbremse ja
natürlich Christians große
Leidenschaft mehr als 50 große deutsche
Unternehmen haben ihn gerade
aufgefordert die Bremse zu modernisieren
die Wirtschaftsweisen sind jetzt
erstmals geschlossen dafür sie zu
lockern oder sparfetisch gut immerin
Spar er Linden auch bei sich selber und
er wird nicht müde es zu betonen wo
können wir sparen ich habe z.B den
Neubau des Bundesfinanzministeriums
abgesagt ich habe beispielsweise ja den
Neubau des
Bundesfinanzministeriums abgesagt ich
habe den Neubau des Finanzministeriums
gestoppt ja du hast was gestoppt ist
angekommen hör auf zu schreien so
eigentlich wissen alle dass die
notwendige Modernisierung des Landes gar
nicht mehr aus dem laufenden Haushalt zu
stemmen ist sogar die Union weiß das was
sie aber erst zugeben wird wenn sie
wieder den Kanzler stellt was geht noch
mit dieser Ampel reden wir drüber mit
diesem Olaf Schubert Olaf schön dass du
da bist ja die Ampel ist diese poamuröse
Dreiecksbeziehung noch zu retten
schaffen die es noch bis zum Herbst
25 ein eine amuröse Dreiecksbeziehung ja
das klingt sehr romantisch ich glaube
wenn man es aber jetzt mal politisch
betrachtet dann ist es ja eher eine Art
restebumsen ja also na ja es ist
zumindest keine keine Liebesbeziehung
das muss man sagen ja bei einer
Liebesbeziehung da bleibt man ja
zusammen bis die Kinder aus dem Haus
sind ja man muss sagen es ist ein
Zweckbündnis daran ist nichts
verwerflich aber ist natürlich ein
anderer Ton ja bei so ein Zweckbündnis
da wird jetzt nicht von früh bis abends
ja aus dem Nabel geschlürft s da gibt's
eher kamellentee aus der Schnabeltasse
ja es gibt Reibungen es gibt Klüngel es
gibt Auseinandersetzung ja Gewalt in der
Ehe ist nicht schön aber gehört dazu
ja bei einer Beziehung zu dritt ist
natürlich praktisch da kann ja immer der
der gerade keine haue bekommt aufpassen
dass es fair bleibt und unter diesen
Bedingung würde ich schon sagen dass die
Ampel bis 20 25
durchhält ich ich wünsch es ihn aber
natürlich
nicht man hat das Gefühl die die
Stimmung im Land ist mies wie selten die
Gesellschaft wirkt wahnsinnig gespalten
aber irgendwann müssen wir ja mal wieder
zusammenken wir müssen mal wieder
gemeinsame Schnittmengen finden wie
könnte das
Gelingen schwieriges Feld ja es geht ja
viel um Wut man hört viel von Angst Wut
und Angst verschmelzen ja wir
Psychologen reden mittlerweile von
wungst aber ich glaube die Spaltung wird
natürlich auch ein Stück weit herbei
geredet ja also z.B bei uns in Sachsen
ich kenne dürfer D gibt's keine Spaltung
ja so das sind einfach alle
rechts und natürlich kann die
Zivilgesellschaft nur funktionieren wenn
sie sich immer wieder auf ihre
Grundpfeiler besinnt und diese auch
artikuliert ja auf die Grundwerte der
Gesellschaft ja was weiß ich eben mit
vollen Mund wird nicht gesprochen ja
dass man einer alten Oma über die Straße
hilft auch wenn sie nicht will
unsere Kultur das ist doch ein ein ein
Pfand ja wir haben Friedrich stilliller
wir haben Helene Fischer wir haben also
zwei Topleute ja da am Start was immer
geht Fußball klar Alkohol ja also man
kann sich eine Regierung natürlich nicht
schön reden aber schön saufen ja und
bald sogar schön
kiffen ja ab 1 April Cannabis
Legalisierung kommt Meldung von heute so
wenn man jetzt Umfragen liest hat man ja
den Eindruck es werden eigentlich die
bestraft die Entscheidung treffen also
regieren und die belohnt die meckernd am
Seitenrand stehen will sagen was stimmt
mit uns Bürgern möglicherweise
nicht genau da sage ich jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt ist es bringing point also
ich finde es geht über Engagement warum
sich nicht selber engagieren ja ich wenn
es gut läuft Gründe ich jetzt auch eine
Partei ja das Bündnis Olaf Schubert
Sachsen kurz Boss
ja über Engagement sage ich mal raus aus
dieser Opferrolle ja also ich meine
Opfer sein ist leicht aber opferbringen
darum geht es doch ja die Bauern ich
meine wenn jetzt jeder protestiert ich
meine warum protestieren die Bauern also
ich sag mal wer freiwillig auf dem Land
lebt ja der gibt ja zu dass er vom Leben
nichts mehr erwartet
also ja alle wollen nehmen nehmen nehmen
und das müssen wir überwinden also ich
will nicht nur nehmen ich will auch mal
genommen werden ja
und und darüber vielleicht einen neuen
Optimismus generieren ja ich meine falls
es dazu kommt wenn irgendwann falls man
die AFD den Reichskanzler stellt dann
ist ja automatisch nicht alles schlecht
ja dann schaffen die vielleicht den
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk ab und
dann hätte ich Freitagabend mal
frei gut das will meine Familie nicht
aber irgendw im Schuber vielen
Dank komm wir müssen Strom sparench die
heute machen wir
asmrke
arschkrampe abonniert den Kanal für die
nächsten Schimpfwörter sonst setzt es
was